تشهد العاصمه العراقيه بغداد وقفه
احتجاجيه دعما لقطاع غزه وذلك عقب صلاه
الجمعه في مسجد الامام انس بن مالك بمنطقه
الاعظميه وردد المتظاهرون هتفات مندده
بالعدوان على غزه وجرائم الاباده الجماعيه
بحق اهلها وقد خصصت خطبه الجمعه للتنديد
بالعدوان والمواقف المتخاذل كما القى عدد
من الرموز الوطنيه والاسلاميه كلمات داعمه
لغزه ان ما تق المقاومه من بطولات وتضحيات
يشكل مقمه لنصر
كبيرهد حب الله والشهيد حبيب الله معنا من
الاعظميه في بغداد مراسل الجزيره عبد
الفتاح
[موسيقى]
فايد نعم عبد القادر بالفعل كما تشاهد هذه
المظاهره بدات قبل نحو ساعه من الان خلال
صلاه الجمعه التي خصصت بال كامل لنصره غزه
كما قالوا وتداول على الخطبه بعد تلك
الصلاه العديد من الرموز الوطنيه والدينيه
العراقيه الذين اكدوا وقفتهم هذه ورباطه
مع غزه ونصره لاهلها في مواجهه الاباده
الجماعيه كما يسمونها وحرب التجويع التي
تتعرض لها غزه واعتبروا ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في غزه والملح مات التي تقد
والبطولات التي تقدمها كما قالوا هي مقدمه
للنصر الكبير لتحرير المسجد الاقصى
المبارك واكدوا ان الشعب العراقي بكامله
وبكل طوائفه ومكوناته السياسيه يقف
بالكامل مع قطاع غزه ويقف في مواجهه حرب
الاباده والتطهير العرقي التي يتعرض لها
الفلسطينيون في قطاع غزه وايضا في الضفه
الغربيه وتنديد بهذه الجرائم وبالدول التي
تساند الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما قالوا في
ارتكاب هذه الجرائم وفي حصار قطاع غزه
وايضا بالمواقف المتخاذل لبعض الحكام في
حصار غزه وفي ايضا عدم نصره القطاع وعدم
نصره الفلسطينيين في مواجهه هذه الحرب
الخطيره طبعا كما تشاهدون هذه المظاهره
بدات بوقفه احتجاجيه امام مسجد انس بن
مالك بمنطقه الاعظميه
ثم اصبحت تحولت الى مسيره تجوب شوارع حي
الاعظميه من مسجد الامام انس ابن مالك الى
مسجد ابي حنيفه النعمان وهو الرمز الكبير
في حي الاعظميه ببغداد بمنطقه الرصافه في
بغداد هذه الوقفه متواصله وهي وقفه ثابته
يقوم بها العراقيون في كل يوم جمعه دعما
لغزه ونصره لها ويعتبرون ان مثل هذه
الوقفات هي جهاد الموقف وهو نظرا لخا
هم يقومون بهذا الجهاد جهاد الموقف كما
يقولون دعما للمجاهدين في قطاع غزه ونصره
لهم نعم عبد ال